hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
the term bad conscience
schlechtickavissen in
german is in the very title of the
second essay of nietzsche's genealogy of
moral so you can expect that it is going
to be
a centrally important concept
and nietzsche is discussing conscience
at several different points and i think
it's important to begin
by noting where he's talking about
conscience without
calling it bad conscience and this is
early
on in the work in chapters
two and three he he asks the free
person right the person who has a
measure
of value looking out on others from
himself he honors or despises
he also holds himself to something right
he says what do we call this dominating
instinct supposing he feels the need to
give it a name
the answer is beyond doubt this
sovereign man
calls it his conscience right
so being aware of oneself
as a self that has obligations that can
promise that has an agency and
nietzsche goes on in section three to
say his conscience
it is easy to guess that the concept of
conscience that we hear encounter in its
highest
almost astonishing manifestation has a
long
history and variety of forms behind
it to possess the right to stand
security for oneself and to do so with
pride
to possess the right to affirm oneself
this is he says
a ripe fruit right but also a
late fruit so this is something that we
grasp as
as you know people in modernity
and he might say that this was running
throughout antiquity the middle ages
early modernity as well
but it's not there necessarily in human
prehistory instead there's a whole
variety of forms of consciousness
conscience uh and we want to think about
this thing that we call
bad conscience in a very broad sense
schlecta right bad not necessarily
in terms of being the common persons
thing
because as we're going to see it's not
really a commoner's prerogative
at the start although perhaps you know
with culture spreading it becomes so
with the bourgeoisie right
uh in you know early modernity and and
beyond
um and it's connected with this issue of
guilt
it's also connected with punishment it's
connected with all sorts of
other things but it can be understood in
its own
terms and nietzsche only really
approaches this
on its own uh ground in
section 16 and onward and it very
quickly veers into a discussion
of gods and religion that we're going to
skip
over here so in the beginning of chapter
16 he says
at this point i can no longer avoid
giving a first
provisional statement of my own
hypothesis concerning the origin of the
bad conscience
and he says it may sound strange but i
regard the bad conscience as the serious
illness
that man was bound to contract under the
stress of the most fundamental change
he ever experienced and what is that
fundamental change
when he found himself within the walls
of society
and peace so when things were actually
working for human communities
then the bad conscience emerges
in its its fullness but it actually
emerges even
earlier than that when peace is being
imposed by war when one form of conflict
is giving
way to other forms of conflicts as well
and so what is his hypothesis he says
the bad conscience
has its origin in repressed
instincts in drives that that human
beings
have and it's a particularly
uh it's it's a disease he's saying
that's particularly targeted
at the powerful at the people who have
greater instincts greater drives a
greater wish to dominate
to express what he's calling here their
instinct for
freedom and so he you tell here's some
some examples of it he says that
all instincts that don't discharge
themselves outwardly turn inwardly
so what happens well the man who
from lack of external enemies and
resistances
forcibly confined to the oppressive
narrowness and punctiliousness of custom
impatiently lacerated persecuted naughty
at assaulted and
maltreated himself this animal that
rubbed itself raw against the bars of
the cage
as one tried to tame it this
fool this yearning and desperate
prisoner became the inventor
of bad conscience and where did they
invent it in themselves
in in how they're uh dealing with this
so it stems from the condition
of the noble of the powerful within the
confines of something new
the state the political organization
and here we have to talk about how this
this
actually happens so he tells us
that this is in section 17
the welding of a hitherto unchecked and
shapeless populous
into a firm form was not only instituted
by an
act of violence but also carried to its
conclusion by nothing of acts of
violence
the oldest state appeared as a fearful
tyranny right
and you might say oh that's great for
the masters right they all have their
place in tyrannizing everybody else
not exactly so he goes on and he says
i employed this word state what does it
mean some pack of
beasts of prey a conqueror and master
race
organized for war and with the ability
to organize lays its terrible claws upon
a populist perhaps tremendously superior
numbers
but still formless and nomad this is how
the state began
on earth didn't begin with a contract it
didn't begin with you know some election
instead he who can command who is by
nature master who is violent in act and
bearing
they are the ones who impose and he
calls these the most involuntary
unconscious artists right it says
wherever they
appear something new arises a ruling
structure that lives
in whose parts and functions are
delimited and coordinated
in which nothing whatever finds a place
that has not been assigned a meaning
right and so we've got these noble
people an
aristocracy imposing themselves
upon others now you know is this a very
plausible
explanation of the origin of the human
state
you know the story is more complicated
than that but obviously
power dynamics do play an important part
in it and whenever we
look at things and you know this is this
is
important so within the imposition of
the state the development of the state
what we have is those who are strong
those who
exhibit their freedom through violence
they impose upon
others they impose upon themselves
as well form and he goes on and
and says here we go
these people don't know what guilt
responsibility or consideration
it are these born organizers they
exemplify that terrible artist's egoism
right that that imposes upon others it
is not in them that the bad conscious
develops
that goes without saying but it would
not have developed without them
so these these people who organize
who impose from the top they
create the bad conscience not so much in
themselves
but in their fellow nobles in all of
those who
are then required to become part of the
apparatus
of the state of the culture who
aren't the king who aren't the great war
leader
but are subordinates in certain ways
so he goes on and he says that
it's the same active force that is at
work on a grander scale
in these artists of violence and
organizers who build states
and on a smaller and pettier scale
directed backward into the labyrinth of
the breast
which creates for itself a bad
conscience that builds
negative ideals so the instinct for
freedom right the instinct for freedom
which he
tells us is in his language
the will to power this is a central
nation concept
gets repressed and turned inward
by these people who are part of the
aristocracy
they're not commoners but they're not
the absolute rulers the shapers
and instead they can only work within
and upon
themselves we've already encountered one
group of people like this the priests
right
nietzsche doesn't talk about the priests
here he's talking about
others within this warrior class
who are also developing something
within themselves so
he goes on and he tells us
that here we go um
this is this is you know an active bad
conscience
that's being developed he also uses this
term
internalization to discuss this turning
inward foreign right a going
inside of oneself and he's got something
really interesting to say here
about this internalization of the human
being right
an animal soul that turns upon itself
going back to this this part in section
16
all instincts that do not discharge
themselves outwardly
turn inward this is what i call the
internalization of man
thus it was that man first developed
what was later called his soul
the entire inner world originally as
thin as if it were stretched between two
membranes
expanded and extended itself acquired
depth breadth and height
in the same measure as outward discharge
was inhibited
those fearful ball works with which the
political organization protected itself
against the old instincts of freedom the
fact that the strong want to be strong
right
they want to exert their will to power
on other people but it's being hemmed in
what happens they develop interiority
you know he says brought about all these
that that all these instincts of wild
free prowling man turn
backwards against man himself
hostility cruel joy and persecuting and
attacking in change and destruction
all this turned against the possessors
of these instincts that is the origin he
says
of the bad conscience so this is
something
new right an animal soul turned against
itself
taking sides against itself as he says
and there's a long passage in section 18
where he talks about this
burning a no into
one's self this is actually quite
interesting here
so he tells us that this instinct of
freedom
is the material upon which the
form-giving and ravishing nature of this
force
vents itself man himself his whole
ancient animal self so the self is
working upon the self if i can't
break things and do all sorts of crazy
stuff
externally because i'm hemmed in because
the king's watching me
and i'm part of his you know military
force i'm going to do it to myself i'm
going to do it inside
is is what's going on here right so he
says
that what what's happening here is that
uh here we go this secret
self-ravishment this artist's cruelty
this delight in imposing a form upon
oneself
as a hard recalcitrant suffering
material and in burning a will
a critique a contradiction a contempt a
no into it this uncanny dreadfully
laborous
joyous labor of a soul voluntarily at
odds with itself that makes itself
suffer out of joy and making suffer
this is the the entire act of bad
conscience right this is what
allows us to become something
new becomes something in certain
respects
greater but also more tortured and like
he says there is a delight in this
a delight in imposing order upon oneself
a delight in making parts of oneself go
along with other parts of oneself
in this reflexivity that it involves
there's even a kind of beauty he says
involved in this as well he says there's
an abundance of strange new beauty and
affirmation
what would be beautiful if if the
contradiction
had not first become conscious of itself
if not the ugly
had not first said to itself i am ugly
and then decided to
change that so he tells us that this
this suggests an ideal a kind of beauty
and self-sacrifice is connected with
this the beauty
and the joy derives from cruelty to
oneself
so this is the you know the the origin
of the bad conscience there's one other
thing that nietzsche says
about this that's particularly important
just like earlier in essay 1 when he
talked about with the figure of the
priest
the human being becomes an interesting
animal
something similar is happening here
he mentions uh in in section 19
the bad conscience is an illness but
illness as
pregnancy is is illness meaning that
something new is coming about because of
it and he
tells us what this is in section
16. he tells us that this animal soul
turned against
itself taking sides against itself
is something so new profound unheard of
enigmatic contradictory and pregnant
with a future that the aspect of the
earth was entirely altered
because human beings bring this about
we change the nature of
the earth itself and the human being's
position
within it as an animal as
a new kind of creature he says
indeed divine spectators were needed to
do justice to this
right from now on man is included among
the most unexpected and exciting lucky
throws
in the dice game of heraclitus's great
child as he called zeus or chance
human beings give rise to an interest
attention a hope almost a certainty
as if with him something we're
announcing and preparing itself
so this guilty conscience this this
bad conscience that now develops within
human beings that gives us a an
additional
interiority the capacity to work upon
ourselves
to be cruel to ourselves to demand of
ourselves
it makes us a different kind of creature
that can now
do things that are otherwise impossible
within the animal kingdom
and he closes on on saying as if man
were not a goal
an endpoint but only away an episode of
bridge a great promise this is a sort of
you know hint about the ubermensch the
person that that
the ordinary person you know the human
being
is just a bridge to and that's where
that section
essentially leaves off so is bad
conscience a thoroughly bad thing
well not exactly it makes us a more
interesting kind of creature
according to nietzsche
you